وصل الأمير فيليب إلى المستشفى
هنا في وسط لندن
يوم الثلاثاء لكن القصر يؤكد
أنه لم يكن دخول طارئ
تم نقله هنا لم يكن
سيارة إسعاف ودخل
المستشفى
دون مساعدة ، وهذا مجرد إجراء
احترازي وفقًا للقصر.
لا يتعلق الأمر بالسرية ، كل ما نعرفه هو
أنه كان على
ما يرام لعدة أيام
ونصحه طبيبه
بالذهاب إلى المستشفى للمراقبة وللحصول
على قسط
من الراحة ، تظل الملكة في حالة رياح
حيث قضى الزوجان الكثير من
الوباء
لكنهم يتوخون الحذر هنا ويحاولون
عدم إثارة قلق الناس من خلال
وضع بعض
العبارات التي قدموها في البيانات هنا ،
لكنه يبلغ من العمر 99
عامًا ومن المقرر أن يكون عمره 100 عامًا في الصيف ،
لذا فهم يتوخون الحذر على ما يبدو
لنكون قراءة جميع البيانات
والمعلومات التي حصلنا عليها
من القصر
ماكس فوستر سي إن لندن